[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is always my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to interview
people who are very good at what they do
to find out what makes them tick their
influences things you can use that you
can borrow from their lived experience
and my guest today is David Eagleman you
can find him on Twitter at David
Eagleman Eagle man and just as you would
think it's spelled and David is a
neuroscientist New York Times
best-selling author Ted speaker and
Guggenheim fellow we're going to come
back to the Guggenheim fellow I think
very shortly he is the writer and
presenter of the Emmy nominated series
The Brain on PBS as well as the podcast
inner Cosmos with David Eagleman in Palo
Alto California he teaches at Stanford
University you may have heard of it runs
a startup neurotech company called
neosensory and directs the Center for
Science and law Dr Eagleman also runs a
film and television production company
Cognito entertainment to bring
scientific themes fiction and
non-fiction to the screen
and in his spare time he is the author
of eight books including the
international bestsellers sum Incognito
I learn I learn and his newest book live
wired you can find all things David at
eagleman.com David's so nice to finally
carve out the time to have this
conversation great great to be here Tim
and I thought we would start with a
topic while near and dear to my heart
it's not something I know that much
about and that is synesthesia and I'll
preface that by saying
one book that I found somehow I don't
know how in high school which later led
to me for a very brief stint being a
neuroscience major or a Psychology major
with a focus on Neuroscience was a book
by A.R luria and I may screw up another
word here but the mind of a
anemoneist neminist I always want to say
pneumonist but like mnemonic device
nemacine the Greek goddess of memory so
that gave me insight as any reader of
this book would find into a vast memory
and what maybe hypernesia or incredibly
unusual performance in that Arena can
look like would you mind just
taking a moment to Define synesthesia
and to then describe the work that
you've done in that area or aspects of
it that you find particularly
interesting so anemones is someone who
can memorize anything in their life as
you know from the book giant lists of
arbitrary numbers or things like that
some people have this ability and it
turns out as far as I can tell anyway
that every single one of these people
has synesthesia so synesthesia is where
there's an association between
some stimulus and something else so for
example numbers triggering a color
experience so three is purple and nine
is yellow and so on but it's not only
colors it can be other things like
gender and personality and shape and
size and things like that so for someone
who has synesthesia
when they're memorizing let's say the
digits of pi there's a whole story
landscape going on where the the small
yellow girl who is number three is
talking to the
angry boy who's number seven and then
who's talking to the the old woman who's
number nine and so on there's a whole
story there and and that's how neminists
tend to memorize their their stuff but
synesthesia turns out is quite common
it's about three percent of the
population has some form of synesthesia
and the thing I've always found
fascinating about it the reason I've
studied it for about 20 years now is
because it is just an example how
reality can be different in your head
and in my head and we would both accept
it as okay that's how the world is there
I should just mention there are all
these forms of synesthesia like you know
hearing might lead to a taste in your
mouth or tasting something might lead to
a feeling on your fingertips or a loud
sound might cause you to see something
or whatever it's just any blending of
the senses we call that synesthesia
all right many follow-up questions
because I've never had a conversation
with someone who has spent the amount of
time looking at synesthesia as you have
so two immediate questions come to mind
so nemonist
would you say that that label applies to
only those who seem to organically have
these abilities and maybe the presence
of synesthesia or does it also apply to
people who develop or learn techniques
for say competing in memory competitions
because they can do things that are
seemingly beyond the reach of
the average human but they're not Kim
Peak reading two books at the same time
one eye on each page let's just say
right so like with many things there's
congenital
which means you're born with it or
acquired which means you get it some
other way so for example
there's congenital synesthesia where
you're born with this mixture of the
senses but acquired is when people take
certain psychedelic drugs and they you
know listen to music and cause them to
see colors and shapes that sort of thing
so yes you could be a neminist that
acquires your skills through hard
training and usually that training
involves just tapping into other
modalities like we're really good at
location all animals really care a lot
about location so you know all the stuff
about memory palaces and whatever and
you're memorizing a sequence by placing
things in your mind in different
locations in your house let's say
so that's the way that somebody trains
is by tapping in and really that's what
synesthesia is about is neighboring
areas of the brain that are sort of tied
together more than you would normally
expect so you know
for somebody who has colored numbers
normally we memorize the numbers or the
weekdays or the months or whatever thing
we're forced to arbitrarily memorize as
a child
Forest Tennessee they tie it into
something like colors or in many cases
spatial location so many synesthetes
have let's say the months of the year
are laid out in front of them so they
say oh oh March is over here and April
is kind of up and to the right of it and
then may is down here and and June July
and it usually circles around their body
that kind of thing but they have a very
spatial sense of the months or the years
or the number line things like that so
we may come back to that but I would
like to jump to something that I think
is
certainly adjacent and that is creating
new senses in some respects and this
makes me think of
one of your probably several TED talks
but can we create a new senses for
humans I saw this quite a long time ago
I put it in my newsletter Bible Friday
because I thought it was very much worth
people watching and considering
not just considering what you had then
but the implications of developing
technology so would you mind describing
outside of congenital synesthesia
outside of goblin philosophy mushrooms
and seeing the Andromeda Galaxy appear
before you as You're Here Pink Floyd
there are other options for developing a
new ability to or new faculty to
perceive the world so would you mind
speaking to sensory addition if that's
the right term to use and maybe we start
with recent progress the whole thing
that got me interested in this a while
ago was understanding just really
thinking about the fact that the brain
is locked in silence and darkness inside
the skull and all it ever sees are these
little electrical signals which also you
know can cause chemical release and so
on but you've just got these
electrochemical signals running around
in the dark and yet when you open your
eyes and look at the world you see
everything in full color and it looks so
rich and so on and you're hearing music
and and you know you're feeling things
on your fingertips and you're smelling
cinnamon and all these things seem like
very distinct
senses to you but they're all made of
exactly the same stuff
which is these electrochemical spikes
and so
I got really interested in this idea of
could we feed information into the brain
via an unusual source and would the
brain just figure it out and so what we
did is we built a vest that had
vibratory Motors on it and this was for
people who were deaf it can capture
sound and turn the sound into patterns
of vibration on the skin from high to
low frequency which is exactly what the
inner ear does
and
and we put it on deaf people and train
them and it turns out that works great
you can learn to hear through your skin
and it's because essentially the brain
doesn't care how the information gets
there as long as it gets there somehow
the brain will figure out what to do
with it and the way it does is by making
correlations with other senses so you
know you see the dog's mouth move and
you feel the Barking on your skin and
your brain figures out oh that's the
sound that goes with that
and so
I gave the Ted Talk on it where I showed
the vest and then in the interim what I
did from that time is I shrunk it down
to a wristband I actually spun a company
off so I should say We Shrunk it down
because the whole company is involved in
this very hard work shrunk it down to a
wristband and we're on wrists all over
the world
and that's not only for deafness but
also for tinnitus ringing in the ears I
can explain how that works if
interesting but also for age-related
hearing loss so as people get older they
lose their high frequencies so we just
use machine learning on this wristband
that listens in real time for The High
Frequency parts of speech like a TH or
an s or a v or a b and it buzzes your
wrist in different ways to let you know
hey I just heard a th I heard a b a V
and so what happens is your ear is doing
all the work at the medium and low
frequencies and The Wristband is just
clarifying what just got said at the
high frequency and turns out that works
like gangbusters your brain can learn to
fuse those signals quite easily and
after a few weeks people you know they
don't need hearing aids it replaces a
hearing aid so your mind fills in the
blanks once you develop the ability to
associate exactly because your mind is
getting the information now through your
wrist through the skin of your wrist
which is essentially acting like a
perfect inner ear
we're just transferring the inner ear to
the skin essentially and and that just
passes the information into the brain
the brain says oh I got it that was
sheep versus sheet versus Chic you know
just figures that it just it gets the
information from the wrist and puts it
all together
so for the risks to work like the vest
did
what was the most important
technological innovation because I think
of the surface area of the vest I'm like
okay
your ability to discern say vibration at
the chest versus the back would be
fairly it would appear to be fairly
straightforward but once you constrain
that to surface area and contact on the
wrist
I would imagine that probably
incorrectly but I would imagine that to
be much more difficult for the user to
parse and learn to decipher it's
actually not because you have very low
spatial resolution on your torso in
other words if I right it's the density
exactly so you have higher on the wrist
but your intuition is right that there's
just less room on the wrist to stick
Motors so we have fewer Motors than we
had on the vest it turns out
we use a
an illusion which is if I stimulate two
neighboring Motors you will feel one
virtual point in between those two modes
it's like binaural beats it's audio yeah
exactly and as I change the amplitude of
those two Motors I can move that virtual
Point around so we're actually
stimulating 128 virtual points on the
wrist as well oh that's clever you
clever bastards good for you so I wanted
to ask about
maybe not
replacement therapy in the sense of
hearing say hearing loss fixing hearing
loss or fixing a
pathology I think that would be fair to
say with tinnitus or tinnitus which I
happen to have so I'd be curious to know
how that works it's not very pervasive
in my lived experience but it does
happen I'd love to know also so this is
a very sloppy compound question you can
choose as you would at a buffet where
you'd like to go with it
what might exist for healthy normals in
terms of augmenting the scope of their
sensory experience I don't expect it
will all become mantis shrimp or
something like that but
I'll mention a name that people might
want to look up Ed cook and I don't know
if you know this name but he trained the
author behind a book called moonwalking
with Einstein to win the national memory
championships in the United States Ed
himself very very high level memory
competitor also fascinated with sensory
substitution and sensory addition
so maybe we could start with the
tinnitus or tinnitus and then go from
there to what do you think the
applications are or could be for healthy
normals if that makes sense so first
thing by the way is that
everyone calls it tinnitus and
audiologists call it tinnitus and either
one is correct so okay great good second
thing is the way it works is something
that is so simple it's called bimodal
stimulation but all it is is we're
playing tones
around the around your tinnitus
frequency and
and you're feeling the corresponding
buzzes on your skin
so you're hearing the sound in your ears
and you're feeling the buzz on your skin
that drives down the tinnitus as much as
any solution that exists the reason it
works there are very complicated
arguments but I think the simple thing
is that you're teaching the brain what
is a real external sound because the
skin is giving you verification that the
sound actually is real it's external
yeah exactly opposed to the B IB on the
inside which is fake news or originating
externally yeah exactly exactly but the
stuff on the inside isn't real and it
doesn't get verification or confirmation
on the wrist and so your brain figures
out oh okay I don't need to pay as much
attention to that so that's how that
works which is cool
so we're doing all these things in the
hearing space and that's actually what
my company neosensory is on the market
with because that's all a very direct
path but the really interesting thing is
we've got 70 projects 7-0 different
projects about sensory addition and
sensory expansion
some of my favorites are things like for
a long time I've been wearing infrared
just so I can pick up on what's going on
in the infrared range you can actually
do this in the near infrared or the
midwave infrared but in the near
infrared the first time I put it on I
happen to be walking at night time in
between a couple houses and I suddenly
felt all this infrared radiation but I
couldn't figure out where it was come
from so I just followed my wrist
and there was a security camera with
infrared LEDs which normally is totally
invisible to you you can't see that but
it was so obvious to me that the
security camera was there because I
could feel it
but in the mid-range that's when it's
really interesting because that's the
temperature that's where it's picking up
heat signatures and so I can like walk
through the parking lot and know
immediately which cars have been parked
there a while which ones have just
pulled up in the last half hour because
there's a lot of heat coming from the
engine block I can just feel that or
when I happen to go in the library the
first time I was wearing this and you
know I could tell there were two empty
chairs I could tell which one was satin
at some point in the last half hour
because there's still a heat signature
there and even even the books on the
display where people have recently
picked up a book they still leave The
Heat Signature there so it's really
amazing it's like slicing up time in a
different way when you're tapped into
the infrared range but but we have all
kinds of projects where you can feed in
data from the Internet stock market data
Twitter data
one of the cool things that we did is we
took one of these smart watches that can
pick up on your you know galving skin
response and heart rate and heart rate
variability and that stuff and then we
using the API we fed that data out and
over the internet and then to the The
Wristband so you can feel all that but
the interesting part is when you take
the wristband off and put it on someone
else so let's say your spouse is tapped
into your physiology and your spouse can
feel the things that you're time to
leave to Maloney's dysregulated
[Laughter]
useful thing for marriages but it is
totally cool to be able to know when
someone else is feeling stressed I mean
you can be the reason we did this over
the Internet is you can be on the other
side of the globe and you can suddenly
call your wife and say you know hey baby
you stressed out you know you're feeling
okay and anyway it's just a really
interesting thing so we're exploring
lots of things none of them have clear
Market paths but they're the thing that
feed me scientifically of the 70
experiments slash projects that you have
running why did you choose the infrared
for yourself because several of them are
clinical they have to do it let's say
for example for prosthetic legs or
peripheral neuropathies or whatever you
know we're just feeding data in but but
because I don't have any of those
problems
not yet knock on wood right it turns out
that I into the idea of sensory
expansion can I tap into other things
and one of the things as maybe you
remember from my TED Talk one of the
things I've always been fascinated by is
how little we see of the world we see
such a tiny fraction of what is
happening out there so I've always
wanted to be tapped into a lot more just
as an example you may remember between
the Ted talk you know the amount
what we call visible light the roygbiv
that's less than a 10 trillionth of the
light that's out there of the
electromagnetic spectrum and so
it turns out that
you know all these other things x-rays
microwaves and gamma rays all these
things are passing through your body
totally invisible to you because you
don't have the proper receptors to pick
up on it
but I suspect there are
a whole bunch of Nobel prizes hidden out
there in different parts of the spectrum
if we could just pick up on those and
detect them
in our daily lives and and be aware of
things and by the way I should clarify
one thing on that we have all kinds of
ways of detecting things in in the
Spectrum in those different parts but
only in the laboratory we're not walking
around and experiencing the world that
way and I think that's what makes all
the difference I'll just give you one
example just to clarify what I'm saying
some colleagues of mine have this
company where they look in the microwave
range at the oceans to see where the
ships are going and they can make
estimates of Commerce that way and so on
but what they discovered quite
accidentally is that if you look at
water in the microwave range you can
tell if it's drinkable or not you can
tell what water is drinkable and what's
not and nobody knew that before it's
just one of the things we have to look
and say oh hey did you notice this and
so that's what I think we are set up for
is so many discoveries of just being in
the world
having different types of Vision on the
world what are your if you had to
maybe Edge into the realm of Science
Fiction but inform science fiction could
just be informed projection let's say in
the next five years
what would be your wildest hopes
or dreams for the future of this type of
Technology
one of them is that I think we can
really use Ai and machine learning for a
lot of very useful stuff I'll give you
one example of actually a company that's
spun off from our company which is
these three college students who are
doing this awesome thing to
help people with Autism understand the
social context that they're in so kids
with autism usually can't tell if the
person they're talking to is angry or
happy or sad or whatever so this The
Wristband just uses
machine learning to listen and say oh
that person is angry or happy or sad or
whatever and then just buzzes to tell
you the right answer and this kind of
thing is so useful
you know obviously we are in the middle
of this explosion of what's going on in
Ai and to be able to use that and do
some very sophisticated thing and then
just feed the data back into the user
and just tell the user the simple answer
to the very complicated thing going on
out there I think we'll we're just going
to see so much of that happening are
there any other applications that that
come to mind and it doesn't have to be
human-centric it could be something
like the augmentation you described with
microwave range and the potability of
water
but any other applications come to mind
you know one that we proposed a long
time ago and we sort of did a tiny bit
of work on is about stock market data
summarizing what's happening in the
stock market and moment to moment you
can feel it on your skin
you know or you can there are many ways
to do it with whole patterns or just
like hey I want to follow Google and
meta and whatever and and you can feel
what's going on and what I'm interested
in
is if we train someone for the long term
on this can they get to the point where
they say
hey I just have this feeling this gut
feeling that oil is crashing right now
or something without even being
perceptually aware of what all these
signals are what they mean can they just
develop a direct perceptual experience
of the economic movements of the planet
just developing trading intuitives Yeah
by feeding them lots and lots of data
because that's all vision and hearing
and all this stuff is we just we
experience a lot today when you're a kid
when you're a baby you don't know how
the heck to use your eyes or ears or
whatever you're just getting all this
data going into the darkness there and
you figure stuff out you figure out
correlations it also ties in and I I
suspect we won't go too deeply on this
but it relates to Ai and also just
technology in general machine learning
as well because it turns out some of the
things we might have assumed to be very
very complex like playing chess playing
go
are very easy to train machines for
whereas if you want a machine to catch a
ball if you want a machine to walk in
some capacity do things that we say for
granted drive a car
some of the simplest things turn out to
be the hardest things and it seems to me
that underscores
in a way how unaware most of us are of
how much we are processing at any given
point in time yeah it's remarkable this
by the way is why I wrote my book
Incognito some years ago which is about
everything that's running under the hood
that we don't have access to I mean the
amount
that your conscious mind has access to
is it you know it's the broom closet in
the Mansion of the brain
the part where you say oh yeah I'm aware
of this I mean look you know I'm raising
this cup of water to my mouth I have no
idea how I'm doing the thing with my arm
and my elbow and getting into my mouth
all I am aware of is whether I spilled
it on myself or not and it's like that
with everything in your life getting a
joke falling in love driving a car all
this stuff is happening totally
unconsciously yeah how do you think
these days
this is going to be a bit of a broad
question there's probably a better way
to put it but about memory and
specifically the reason behind the
question or recall let me make it more
specific
is that
we learn we forget or we use these terms
in ways that imply we know what those
mean
and I've had experiences where
say I studied language long ago 10 15 20
years ago at the time I was pretty
decent but if you were to put me in
circumstances that required German right
now I would not be able to perform
but
in certain States whether that's in
say a non-ordinary state of
consciousness induced by psychedelic
compounds or others it's not the only
one
in periods of say very deep ketosis
where I'm doing say an extended fast and
I have 2.53 millimolars of of BHB
measured by fingerprint
I do then appear to have access to these
memories I had assumed I had forgotten
in quotation marks how do you think
about these things
first of all I'd love it I'd love to
actual test with you on like what I mean
is for example we could just pull up
online some you know basic German test
where you're doing something and see
whether when in deep ketosis if you have
a better score than you do verify it for
sure yeah because if that is verifiable
that's amazing and cool and what it
illustrates is something that we do know
which is that that stuff is in there
and we know this for several reasons I
mean the big one is
if somebody says a German word let's say
that you haven't heard in years but you
say oh yeah that's right I remember that
I mean all that stuff's in there the
other thing is there's there's a
psychological Effect called savings
which is
let's say you've studied German for a
long time then you don't study it for
years but then you pick it up again you
say okay I'm gonna get really serious
and study this you'll be much faster at
learning it because all that data is in
there in some form it's in there and so
it's much much faster the second time
around
just as an example when astronauts come
back from orbit they have to relearn how
to walk but it doesn't take them as long
as it doesn't infant they you know
they're first they can't really walk on
their own and then they're walking fine
so what is fascinating and maybe this is
part of what you were getting at with
your question is we use the word memory
in computers and it's such a shame that
we use the same word because there's
hardly any relationship their memory in
a computer is perfect they're putting in
zeros and ones you get those same zeros
and ones back out in in a human brain
it's a totally different thing going on
and in my in my last book live wired I
talk about how memory actually has to
get moved around in the brain and moved
into different states
and there's all kinds of weird stuff
here I'll just I'll flag one or two
which is one of them is that memory
actually has to be reconsolidated after
you take it out of long-term storage so
maybe you knew this but let's say to a
listener if I ask you what's the name of
your fifth grade teacher
you haven't thought about that
presumably in a very long time so you
bring that out of Cold Storage that's
called and you and you're thinking about
it now now it's an active memory
represented by spikes running around in
the brain if you get hit in the head
right now
that'll be gone it'll be gone or if I
give you a protein synthesis inhibitor
meaning that you've you've brought it to
the bullpen so to speak but now it's
vulnerable to interruption in such a way
that it would not make its way back to
Cold Storage is that what you mean
that's exactly right exactly right to
not realize that yeah a memory needs to
be reconsolidated it needs to be taken
from activity back to
into the structure of the system and so
it's vulnerable to Erasure super weird
but I'll just as a side note
scary memories very emotionally charged
memories are not erasable those are
unerasable which sucks actually because
those are the ones that you know trauma
victims often want to erase but um
you have what amounts to a secondary
memory system that says hold on to that
because that's the really important
stuff are there any researchers
who come to mind could be thinkers
writers
who are
doing a really interesting job of just
examining the question of what if
anything gets permanently deleted to
come back to the human versus computer
because I've been shocked
how things can Surface from the recesses
of my mind that I assumed had long been
sent to the landfill right there's let's
just say sort of this active working
memory then you have the cold storage
long term and I assumed like okay at
some point the warehouse is full things
get taken to the landfill but lo and
behold
certainly recognition is easier but at
points I've also had the recall
is there
any particular researcher or any
resources that are looking institutes
who are looking at this
in interesting ways
that's a very tough question to address
it's something that we make observations
on in our own lives right and how would
you test it yeah particularly
challenging one one of the things that
people do test which is slightly
different than what you're asking but
it's about the way that memory
even though we believe the part that we
do remember is accurate it's the way
that that drifts and
the way that memory is not so just as an
example my colleague Liz Phelps at NYU
right after
September 11 2001 she went interviewed a
bunch of people and said you know what
exactly did you see on September 11th
and she was also clever enough to ask
them tell me your memories from
September 10th the day before they say
okay well I ate lunch here I did this
whatever okay then she found these same
people a year later and asked them and
it turns out both the highly emotional
charge memories and the boring memories
had both drifted it turns out that
everything drifts even things that you
think could you could never get wrong
people get wrong all the time so memory
is a myth-making machine and we're
constantly Reinventing our past
especially as we tell the stories over
and over again yeah totally this is
part of why I'm very skeptical of
certain say studies involving nutrition
and that are observational studies where
they they rely on self-reporting but
people are filling in the Diary of what
they ate asynchronously and I'm like oh
man I would bet people are going to be
20 off minimum on average with that type
of reconstruction that doesn't even
include the purposeful lying that people
do on that right right so let's shift
maybe back in time a bit I know we've
been talking about a number of the books
and I'm going to come back to
live wired but I wanted to ask you about
influences and maybe we could start with
one who some folks will recognize but
Francis Craig how did you meet Francis
Crick
I did my post-doctoral fellowship at a
place called The Salk Institute and
that's where Francis Crick was and
for anyone who doesn't know you know he
was the co-discoverer of the structure
of DNA
and just figured out all these massively
important things in molecular biology he
was essentially the Titan of the 20th
century in biology and I like many
people I think had had assumed he had
already passed away or something I
didn't realize he was still trucking
along but the thing that was so special
about that guy was that he didn't have
any of the constraints that other
scientists did so
other scientists all have to whatever we
write grants we write papers mentoring
grad students whatever reading
applications
but because he won his Nobel Prize when
he was young he just didn't have any of
that and as a result he was able to just
spend 100 of his time doing deep
thinking and and that was it I yeah I
walked into his office he had a stack of
all the journals there you know science
and nature and journal and Neuroscience
so he was flipping through and when he
asked him I said you know what what is
he looking for he looks like he was
looking for something he said I don't
know I'm just looking yeah anyway he was
an amazing guy precisely because he was
so high IQ so high Octane and had no
other constraints on him I've never
known anyone who happened to be in that
position before so when you mentioned
the the 70 projects which I understand
is within the context of a a for-profit
company so it would make sense to
examine a lot of things but if I just
look at your bio
I see many different projects many
different irons in the fire
and I'm looking at an older New Yorker
piece this is from 2011 and as it
relates to Crick who died in 2004 so the
advice and you can't believe everything
you read but I'd love to hear you maybe
expand on this or speak to how it
impacted you
is the dangerous man this is quoting
Crick the dangerous man is one who has
only one idea because then he'll fight
and die for it the way real science goes
is that you come up with lots of ideas
and most of them will be wrong
that's right what impact did that have
on you
well I think if anything that just sort
of meshed with the way I already thought
about things confirmed what you wanted
to do yeah exactly hold on let me take a
one second tangent here which is the
worst piece of advice I ever had was
when I was in college there was a
professor an electrical engineering
professor of mine and I really liked the
guy and and he said me one day he said
look Eagle man life is like you're a
lumberjack and you go into the forest
with your ax you got to pick one tree
and you just hit that tree if you take a
whack at all the trees you're not gonna
get anywhere and it sounded so wise and
so reasonable and so on but it's just
not who I am I'm just not the you know
pick one tree guy and so I think it
already I think it already preach into
the choir here yeah
yeah exactly and by the way any any good
scientist is doing this anyway you have
lots of hypotheses each one of which you
think wow that's gonna crack open
something big and then you realize oh
that's totally wrong you run experiment
or whatever so you got to have a lot of
them so let's let's say you didn't have
the podcast which people should check
out inner Cosmos David Eagleman didn't
have the production company you didn't
have any obligations outside of science
but
you had done something maybe it was
winning a Nobel Prize where you had the
same ability to sit in your office sit
in your lab and basically do whatever
you want hmm
what types of
outside of reading widely and having
piles of things on your desk perhaps as
Cryptid are there any hypotheses
or experiments that you would
have at the top of your list
for things to pay attention to yeah lots
of them I mean I think most of my career
has been defined by trying to understand
how the brain constructs reality you
know you've got all these spikes running
around and the question is how does that
make this subjective reality we have
with all its colors and sounds and
tastes and smells and so on why does
this biological activity in a whole
bunch of cells feel like something
that that feels to me like the biggest
central question in Neuroscience but
there are lots of I actually wrote an
article I think in 2004 2006 I wrote the
cover article for discover magazine and
I called it 10 unsolved questions of
Neuroscience and I defined 10 questions
and
and these are still equally as unsolved
now as they were way back then and so I
feel like you know there's there's just
there's so much really rich stuff to
answer but anyway Consciousness really
sits at the middle and by the way for
Francis Crick this was one of his
Central questions also maybe maybe the
central question that he devoted the end
of his life to how do you put together
86 billion cells and get experience get
meaning out of it
let's talk about Consciousness for a
second which is such a Slippery Pig
that's I know some folks hate talking
about it because they're like oh it's
like talking about God we might not even
be talking about the same thing like
let's define terms but
for the moment we can we can put that
aside although if you have a tidy
definition I'd love to hear it but
do you think that Consciousness is an
emergent property so at some point these
building blocks these carbon-based
structures build up and then we have at
some point Consciousness as an immersion
property or do you feel and maybe
there's a third answer that it is more
fundamental than that
I don't think there's any way to know so
just to Define that for the audience the
second view is sometimes called pan
psychism Which is that maybe
Consciousness is a fundamental quality
of the cosmos and you know like gravity
or mass or whatever it is
you know it's already there and you're
putting things together in in just the
right way
and the first version is that you know
if you put a bunch of cells together
just the right structure
you get self-awareness and sentience
we don't really know yeah and all the
data we have is consistent with either
so the data we have on consciousness of
course is that you know if you hurt your
brain
let's say with a stroke or a tumor or
traumatic brain injury or whatever
or or you put molecules in like drugs
your Consciousness can change in any of
these circumstances
but
all that tells us is that the physical
Integrity of the system is necessary for
the conscious experience but it
certainly could be either
what was quick trying to solve for how
is he trying to examine
Consciousness and I know pan psychism
has developed a bit of a I don't say
negative connotation but even even some
physicists who I guess are taking the
understanding that I couldn't even begin
to explain how one might test this
experimentally so I assume it's largely
theoretical at this point but those who
take the Consciousness as fundamental
side of things seem to try not to use
pan psychism
some of them but
how is Crick approaching this and why
was it so
compelling well let me say two things
okay so Crick had a chalkboard in his
office and he had lots of things written
on it but right in the middle he had the
word meaning written on it because that
was his Central questions why does any
of this mean anything to us right I mean
if I if I look at my garage door opener
or my cell phone or whatever it's just
pushing zeros and ones around and
transistors and presumably nothing means
anything to it but we have all this
feeling and meaning so that was a
central question and what he was trying
to figure out was what he called the NCC
the neural correlates of Consciousness
so working with our mutual colleague
Christoph Coke he was working on the NCC
and trying to figure out okay look
there's the hard problem of
Consciousness which is why does any of
this equal subjective experience but the
maybe easier problem is to figure out
what parts of the brain are involved and
absolutely have to be there for you to
be consciously aware of something and so
that's what he you know he's sort of
defined that as a program and worked on
that until he passed away but there are
many other people who are pursuing that
in various ways and so again that's the
easy problem of Consciousness just
figuring out the correlates yeah it's
exciting
are there any of the 10 unsolved
questions if I'm getting the the
headline right of Neuroscience of those
10 are there any if you're like you know
what if I could have an X prize
put something together to make it so
financially compelling that some of the
best scientists in the world would drop
what they are doing to focus on this
this is the one or the two that I might
choose
are there any that come to mind they
don't even necessarily need to be from
that piece they could be
something that simply comes to mind
actually let me give a slightly
different answer to the question because
actually when I thought you were gonna I
thought you might be about to ask are
there any of the ten that we have sort
of made some progress on and actually
there is one there is one and that has
to do with why we dream you know one of
the questions was why do brains sleep
and dream sleep is still a little
complicated but you know the bunch of
hypotheses but I think that my student
and I solved why we dream at night
and I can tell you if you're interested
in that of course no thanks yeah we're
in a rush here yeah please please go
ahead David it has to do with brain
plasticity so the brain is always
reconfiguring itself it's a very dynamic
system
and you know every one of these neurons
in your head would they look like you
know branching trees and they make 10
000 connections to other neurons these
are constantly moving so imagine like
moving trees that are plugging and
unplugging and seeking and connecting
with others and so on so anyway that's
called brain plasticity this constant
reconfiguration and it turns out the
surprise in Neuroscience is how rapidly
things can start moving and changing and
so some colleagues minded Harvard back
in
I think 2007
did this experiment where they put
people in in fmri the brain scanner and
they blindfolded them tightly and they
were doing things like you know when
you're exposed to sound or touch what is
that you know what's happening in the
brain and what they found is that in 60
minutes
the visual system started responding to
touch and to sound and that was really
unexpected because we know that if you
go blind your visual system will get
taken over
especially as if you're really young but
no one would have ever dreamed that
you'd start seeing the first signs of
Takeover in 60 minutes and so that got
my student and I to start thinking about
something right away and we realized
that dreaming has to do with the
rotation of the planet and this is
because
you know the planet rotates Into
Darkness so we spend half our time in
the dark obviously I'm not talking about
electricity blessed times but historical
evolutionary times
what this means is
you can still hear and smell and taste
and touch in the dark but you can't see
in the dark and that puts the visual
system at a disadvantage it's like you
have been blindfolded in a sense and so
what we realized is
the visual system has to fight back to
to keep its territory all during the
night and so that's what dreaming is
about every 90 minutes you've got these
very specialized circuits that blast
activity just into the visual cortex
that's all that happens in dreaming is
it's going just to primary visual cortex
all this random activity
and it's just to keep it defended
against takeover from its neighbors to
prevent the weeds of other senses from
encroaching on the Walled Garden of
vision exactly you got it you got it
it's a screensaver
what's very interesting is a lot of
people have asked me when I present this
I'm presenting this at a big talk at
Stanford tomorrow by the way and you
know a lot of people say like wait don't
we already know why we dream and the
answer is no we don't know how we dream
there are various hypotheses but that
doesn't mean you stop making hypotheses
and the reason this one matters I think
is because it is the first ever one that
makes quantitative predictions across
species so what we did is we
found 25 different species of primates
and we looked at how plastic their
brains are some primates come out very
plastic like Homo sapiens others like
the Greymouth lemur it's called is you
know very not plastic it drops out it
reaches puberty rapidly it knows how to
walk rapidly it it's just it's sort of
pre-programmed if you want to think
about it that way what are you using as
a proxy or a measurement for plasticity
it's time to wean from their mothers
time to walking time to puberty things
like this I got it so how much is kind
of out of the box versus how much is
molding of the Play-Doh you got it
that's exactly it and so homo sapiens
it's unbelievable I mean we're so
useless for so long and that's because
we've got these extraordinary plastic
Brands we drop into the world Half Baked
and we absorb the world around us we
absorb the language and the culture and
all the knowledge that has come before
us and that's why it takes us so long to
develop but you know these are some some
of the other monkeys and apes or
whatever drop out they're good to go and
if you look at something like an
alligator you know it's just like eat
run mate that's all it's doing there's
no there's nothing other than the
pre-programming that it needs okay so
anyway it turns out if you look at the
amount of REM sleep rapid eye movement
sleep rapid eye movement sleep is what
correlates with dreaming if you look at
the amount of REM sleep that these
different animals get you find that it
correlates perfectly like a
perfect machine gun correlation Samora
REM more plasticity exactly by the way
if you're a baby human you dream all the
time they have about 50 percent of their
sleep is REM sleep it's dream sleep
and as you get older your brain is less
plastic and by the way you have less
percentage of REM sleep but anyway for a
an animal that's not particularly
plastic it has very little dream sleep
are you aware of any
counter examples are there any species
that seem to exhibit
a decent percentage of REM sleep but
that one would not conclude are
particularly
High plasticity outside of primates no
no I don't know any counter examples
where they have a lot of REM sleep but I
did come across one which I thought was
a real problem for the hypothesis which
is elephants elephants have almost no
REM sleep they do they have a little bit
of REM once in a while but otherwise
they don't and of course you know
elephants have big brains and so on but
it turns out elephants only sleep one to
two hours a night and they have
excellent night vision so they don't
need to keep their visual cortex
protected against Takeover in the same
way that we do
so that actually falls right into line
in the theory that's fascinating
I wonder if there are other animals with
terrible night vision that might
experience a decent percentage of their
sleep is REM sleep but it's a
fascinating hypothesis right I mean
Super fascinating yeah I mean it
simplifies the whole thing and
demystifies it if if true exactly and
you know again when you're blasting
random activity in because we're visual
animals we have dreams you know when you
get activity back there you think oh I'm
seeing them riding through a meadow I'm
talking to a silver leprechaun
whatever's going on you too
what's funny about dreams is you know
you wake up and you try to explain it to
your spouse or whoever you're talking to
and and we we layer on all this extra
stuff in this narrative to make it make
sense but actually dreams are just these
weird visuals that happen
actually let me just mention one thing
because I always get asked about okay
what about blind people what happens
their dreams do you know the answer to
that I don't I I would suspect it
probably depends on when they became
blind and the type of blindness but I
don't know the answer to that so why
don't you take us there if you are a
blind person you still have dreams at
night and that's because these circuits
that drive dreaming are very ancient you
find these across the entire Animal
Kingdom actually so every 90 minutes
they get this random activity blasted
into their occipital lobe but now that
part of the brain is no longer visual so
a blind person has dreams that's that
involves you know touch and hearing and
so on like oh I was you know feeling my
way around the living room and
and there was a big dog in the corner
and I got scared and I ran but you know
the furniture was all rearranged and
whatever but it's all
touch and hearing it's not visual
yeah you know I I interviewed Richard
Turner who is a very famous close-up
magician who is completely blind and he
became blind at a pretty young age and
he described his experience of reality
and we have to take his word for it of
course but highly visual I didn't ask
him about his dreams I don't think
but really enjoyed the conversation
because he has the dexterity
of a very well trained sighted person
it's nearly impossible to believe that
he is not fully sided with what he can
do with his hands it's remarkable for
people who are interested there's a
documentary called delt d-e-a-l-t that
is that is fantastic about Richard
Turner oh I'd love to see that it's
fantastic I really recommend it there's
there's a lot more to it than just magic
I mean it's mostly his life story but I
just want to point out it's not
necessarily visual it's spatial so you
know he's got this amazing spatial sense
it sounds like about what's where and
how to turn things and how to move
things and get things into his pocket or
whatever but it's it's spatial well he
describes it as in his experience
keeping in mind that he was cited until
he was something like six or seven years
old I can't recall exactly but if I
remember correctly
different experiences have a blue or a
red tone to them
and have different
I think he would say visuals are
geometric representations depending on
what he is interacting with who he's
interacting with that doesn't invalidate
what you said
with respect to Dreaming I don't think I
asked him that
but that's an area I know very little
about just found him to be a really
fascinating case oh I'd love to get in
touch with him and ask him about his
Dreams yeah he's in San Antonio Texas I
could put you in touch great if you
wanted let's talk about additional
influences so we we hit one of the big
names Crick who are some of the other
influences that most shaped where you
are today and over the last say 10 years
as a scientist and just investigator
of the world I would say the ones that
come to mind are first of all my father
who is a forensic psychiatrist and just
a super smart guy that was a big
influence in my life then I went to
graduate school and
my advisor was gonna read Montague who
was such a terrific
thinker and a great athlete
and he was a major influence on me and
the other one I guess was Carl Sagan you
know who I only know through television
but that was all I saw as a kid we never
watched much TV but I saw Cosmos on PBS
and it totally
influenced the shape of the trajectory
of my life I mean I just first of all so
turned on by all the stuff he was saying
and it's interesting actually because my
parents never said oh you could be the
next president of the United States they
always would say oh you could be the
next Carl Sagan and that you know that's
the direction I ended up taking now I
may have missed the name Montague
Montague yeah Montague what was the
impact
that was made and what sport just just
out of curiosity oh he was a decathlete
he was a decathlete and just
unbelievably good at every sport he ever
tried he was a big Sprinter and a big
muscular guy and somehow when I look
here's the thing as an undergraduate I
majored in British and American
literature because that was my first
love and um and so when I decided in my
last semester of my senior year that I
loved Neuroscience I applied to
Neuroscience graduate school and I
miraculously got in
but I wasn't sure if I wanted to do a
PhD in Neuroscience I didn't know what
that would entail I figured I'd end up
with big coke bottle glasses and my hair
sticking up everywhere I didn't really
know what what it meant to be a
scientist and so I met this guy and he
was so admirable in all the ways that I
wanted to be you know just as a as just
a killer in every way and so smart he
was you know 20 IQ points ahead of
everybody and also could bench press and
you know do chin-ups better than
everybody so he broke the mold so he
showed you that you didn't need to be
resigned to the coke bottle glasses was
that it is that proof of concept yeah it
was proof concept and of course you know
the the ideas and the challenges and
whatever that you know it just it opened
up my world it opened up my mind so
enormously
and he was very hard on me I was his
grad student for five years and he was a
total jerk all the time but I love the
guy so much
but he was really hard on me the whole
time yeah
would you in retrospect have it any
other way no is there a version of the
hard that would be better or would have
potentially been better for you or was
it what you needed at the time I suspect
this is different for each person but
for me it worked really well and I had a
coach a track coach in high school it
was the same way he was so mean to me
and it you know brought out my best
behaviors that way
[Laughter]
going from British American lit to
deciding that you're going to apply for
a master's program in neuroscience
seems like a very hard left turn two
questions so he said very luckily
something along those lines I got in but
there's got to be a little more to the
story so what was the pitch maybe in the
form of essays or maybe it's combined
with standardized testing I have no idea
what the prereqs were or the application
process was like but
why decide to dedicate that time to
Neuroscience where you may be buying
yourself a little bit of time to figure
out what was next and then what do you
think if you had to make an educated
guess
helped you to get in from such and
seemingly unrelated field
the truth is that I was always studying
science and so I had tons of science on
my transcript it's just that I didn't
have Neuroscience in particular So what
had happened is I was good at science
growing up and so everyone told me I
feel like everyone gave me bad advice
they said oh you should become an
actuary and do the stuff with math
because I could do math or you should
become a waste engineer because there's
a lot of money in waste engineering like
people had all these proposals that were
so boring and nothing to do with Carl
Sagan and real questions
so what happened is I went to college
and I studied electrical engineering I
took out to physics I took lots of you
know all kinds of things and I couldn't
quite find what was resonating I
couldn't find the thing that I loved
and so I ended up majoring in literature
but I was taking these classes it was my
my last semester that I took a
neuroscience class and by the way the
class I took was taught by a very old
Professor who was using literature from
let's say the 1960s it was a terrible
Neuroscience class but it didn't matter
at all I was totally hooked so it seems
like you had demonstrated scientific
chops right you're not innumerate you
can do math
was there anything else that was key you
think to getting into that program
actually in one of my philosophy classes
we'd been assigned to write a final
project and I don't know like a 12 page
assignment or something I ended up
writing 108 pages on the brain and and
the reason I was writing so much on is
because I went to the library and I over
the course of that last semester read
every book that the library had on the
brain which by the way was not that many
at the time because there just weren't
that many
but I read everything because the one I
showed up for the graduate school
interview I said look I know I don't
have much biology on my transcript but
ask me what I know and I'll tell you
because I've read XYZ and it worked the
problem is I don't think a kid could get
into graduate school now with that
trajectory I think that's a shame why
not well only because now the
competition is so high and so if you
haven't rotated in Labs the whole time
you're an undergrad and been doing
Neuroscience since you were two years
old and so on then it's hard to get in
and then the David eagleman's of the
world end up being waste engineers
oh
no disrespect to waste Engineers but you
would hope there to be a spectrum of
possibilities yeah well it's good that
you went through it when you did then I
suppose yeah oh exactly I really lucked
out
what would you say is one of your for
those people listening and looking at
your bio and watching your TED talks to
think man this guy just wakes up every
morning and just karate chops the
universe to bend his will and his home
runs from start to finish I can't
believe it that's not me
favorite failures and you can Define
that any way you'd like but to frame it
failures or things that didn't work out
as you had hoped that in retrospect
taught you a lot bent your trajectory or
maybe set the stage for later successes
anything that comes to mind
one thing that comes to mind is
I wanted to be a writer very much and so
I wrote my first book called sum s-u-m
great book by the way highly recommend
thank you very much and I submitted for
publication and and I got rejected so I
submitted again I got rejected I ended
up collecting a stack of rejection
letters as high as the book nobody
wanted to publish it most of the reform
rejections but some people hand wrote
stuff saying hey I really liked this
book but I just I have no idea where I
would put this in the bookshelf or where
like I don't even understand what this
thing is and so that was a failure that
just kept dragging on for a very long
time you know I'd written it over seven
years and I was pretty much certain that
it was never actually going to see the
light of day and then finally you know I
just kept trying to crush it from
different angles and I finally came up
with an idea
there was a particular literary agent
that I wanted to hit and so I managed to
figure out three different ways to hit
her so that within 48 Hours she was
hearing from three different people and
so finally she said I will take you on
as a Hip Pocket client which just means
you're not really a client of mine but
I'll keep you in my pocket just in case
I see an opportunity and then she called
me two days later and she was sort of
incredulous and she said wow some just
got bought
and so that was the start of a big thing
and and Tim I know you've read that hold
on so before you get there you're
skipping over something really important
two days later seven years in the making
some just got bought how does that
happen
did she just send it out to some folks
and said I'm never gonna hear back but
[__] it why not let's try it exactly
look it took me a while to learn that
this is what literary agents are about
they're sort of the first filter and if
an agent says I'll take something on
then a publisher will actually take a
look at it but I had been trying to
write to Publishers directly right Tim I
know you know the book and the book
became an international bestseller and
pretty immediately got published in 33
languages it got turned into two operas
Brian Eno turned into an opera at the
Sydney Opera House didn't know that part
that's amazing yes so you know turn into
Opera and then around the same time Max
Richter turned it into an opera at the
Royal Opera House of London and it just
it keeps you know finds itself back in
the top 100 books on Amazon over the
years and so it's just it's been such a
special part of my life but the point is
that it was such a long extended failure
and I'm so thankful that I just kept
banging on that door until it finally
creaked open accidentally
well two questions why write it in the
first place so not to bury this for
people who don't know so some the
subtitle is 40 Tales from the afterlives
that's plural
and you know what if you don't mind I'll
just read what I put in my newsletter
years ago when I first read it and I
won't read all of it but I'll mention
some of it so this is what I put and you
can correct me if I got anything wrong
don't let the title of this book fool
you it isn't making a case for the
afterlife instead this short read easy
to finish one two days is a collection
of 40 thought exercises on the nature of
existence reality perception death pain
boredom and more
at the very least it should make you
appreciate your own life warts and all
much more and then in the official book
description quote in one afterlife you
may find God is the size of a microbe
and unaware of your existence and
another version you work as a background
character in other people's dreams or
you may find that God is a married
couple or that the universe is running
backward or that you're forced to live
out your Afterlife with Annoying
versions of who you could have been end
quote why write this book and
what gave you
the
gumption the persistence to keep going
because that doesn't always happen
to be clear there are plenty of high
achieving people who start books and
finish them get rejected and after a
while they stop so
why why did you end up hitting this
agent for multiple angles so why the
book and then why did you end up
continuing and hitting this agent for
multiple angles why the book actually
started when I was
I think it was like 11 years old and I
ended up talking to a rabbi and I said
hey you know I've never understood what
is the Jewish view of the afterlife and
he said well yes three Jews you'll get
four opinions and I thought that was so
amazing because I never heard someone
say something like that before and so
that was actually the seed of the book
and that's the why the anyways and then
again as a lover of literature and a
writer I just I found this concept of
the afterlife such a great backdrop upon
which to ask all kinds of questions and
as you know from the book it's you know
it's funny and it's
there's Pathos and anyway so that is why
but I do know exactly why I kept going
and that was because of a 16 year old
kid that I met when I was at the
salkinstooth Francis correct actually
what happened is there was a high school
science day and these kids came over and
I talked to them about what I was doing
and one of the kids came up to me
afterwards and said can I work with you
this is what I want to do can I work
with you and I said sure write down your
phone number on the dry erase board here
and he did and the next day the dry
erase board got erased and so I forgot
about the kid okay so then I get a
voicemail from saying hey I'm the kid
okay and then I thought oh I got to call
this guy back and then I forgot and then
I get a letter from his high school
teacher saying hey this is just a letter
to recommend the kid then I get called
from again then I get an email and I
thought wait a minute I don't want to
miss this kid this kid's amazing and so
he ended up working in my lab and for
the last 16 years has been my closest
collaborators Don Vaughn that's
incredible and I call this the dawn
Vaughn method of just hitting someone
over and over from different angles to
make sure that they don't forget anyway
I was so impressed by this because you
know I was busy and I couldn't remember
to call him back and whenever and so I
was really impressed with this and so
when I was trying to get some published
at the end there I thought explicitly
I'm going to do the dawn Vaughn method
and I'm gonna hit this agent from every
angle that I can that's incredible that
it worked yeah it worked that's
remarkable speaking of literature I
think this is from The New York Times a
long time ago but you've said that
Gabriel Garcia Marquez
Italo Calvino Jorge Luis Borges Tony
Morrison and William Faulkner are among
some of your literary influences maybe
Heroes
feel free to add more but I'm curious
for someone who has not read let's
assume someone hasn't read anything from
any of these writers
are there two or three books that come
to mind that you might suggest people
start with
Italo calvino's Invisible Cities is an
extraordinary book
about
Marco Polo talking to the great Khan
Kubla Khan about different cities in the
Khan's Empire and it's it's magical
realism and by the way all five of those
authors that you named that I guess I
named back in that article in 2011. all
five of them they're all magical realism
which means you know it's not just
writing about the day-to-day stuff but
just feeling free to go off in Crazy
directions about things that shouldn't
be possible and they just make it
possible so I've always loved that style
of writing all five of those are really
still my favorites all these years later
yeah 100 Years of Solitude if someone
hasn't read that Borges labyrinths
Tony Morrison's beloved essentially
anything by Faulkner the bear is a great
one I'll add one more to the list for
people who are looking for something
very strange
and it's also very short but I think
it's the baron in the trees by yes Italo
Calvino which is about basically a young
boy who gets in a fight with his father
comes from his esteem family escapes
into the into the tree in his yard and
never comes down for the rest of his
life and he builds this entire life in
the trees in the canopy it's it's about
as strange as it sounds
the word hypothesis has come out a bunch
in this conversation and
you've said in I think it was
Smithsonian Magazine
that you encourage your son to do
hypothesis testing
um could you speak to this and just
explain what that might look like oh
yeah it's anytime he says like Hey Dad
how does this work and I've got a
daughter now too and so you'll say hey
how does this work I say well how do you
think it works what would you so they
come up with an idea and I say okay cool
can you come up with another idea they
come up with another okay great and how
do we test that how would you
distinguish those two ideas so that's
what it is to come up with something on
your own and figure out how to test it
because whether or not they become
scientists I mean I you know they
probably won't for all I know but
definitely want them to be good thinkers
and be able to figure things out so
they're not dependent on Dogma or what
their neighbor tells them is the answer
that sort of thing if you were giving
advice to say let's put you back in the
realm of Academia so you've got
super promising postdoc one of the
smartest you've ever met maybe has some
IP that is spun out or something that is
spun out into a for-profit company
and they come to you to ask for
time management
advice prioritization advice just
general life management and advice
because they fear that they're going to
get overwhelmed they look at your life
they say this is the guy who can do
anything he's the decathlete of business
and science
and put in that situation what advice
might you give them what might you say
to them I would only be able to give
what I do and that is the Lazy Susan
method so do you know what Lazy Susan is
you know it's a circular thing that sits
in the middle of the table you can spin
it around to get different dishes
exactly exactly so it turns out I
learned a long time ago that Walt
Whitman would do this with his writing
projects each segment in the lazy
students need to have a different
writing project and he would work on
something until he was slowing down and
then he'd spin it and randomly pick a
different project and work on that and
that is precisely what I do I loved
seeing that story about him because
that's that's my life I work on whatever
I am maximally resonating with at that
moment as soon as I started slowing down
or get stuck I just jump to a different
project and when I come back to the
thing I had been working on I'm sort of
you know more refreshed in a sense or
I've thought of a new idea about it that
kind of thing where do you keep this
Lazy Susan presumably it's not a
physical Lazy Susan not physical just in
my prefrontal cortex yeah spinning
around there if we could take a closer
look at this prefrontal Lazy Susan for a
second
let's just take this upcoming week so
we're talking on a Monday
and I don't know what your calendar
looks like maybe you could just describe
the architecture of your week a little
bit that would actually be very helpful
a lot of it is work meetings with my
company neosensory some of it is
meetings with VCS about that
then I have various lectures I'm giving
it happens that this week several of
them are virtual lectures so that's a
lot easier for me
then working on how to do B2B stuff
business to business stuff because we're
now we're now selling the wristband
not only to customers but directly to
big businesses with big warehouses for
their deaf employees but then let's see
I'm giving a talk
to a bunch of Stanford students then
I I run the Center for Science and law
which is where Neuroscience in the legal
system intersects so having some
meetings about that
I also just finished a book about
okay this is a little embarrassing
because it's so unusual it's so
different than anything else I've
written but it's a young adult book or
middle grade
but it's about a brother and sister team
who solve Mysteries like hearty boys or
Encyclopedia Brown but all the Mysteries
have to do with the brain so it's really
I think educational and lovely so I'm
having a meeting about that and then it
happens that tomorrow's my birthday so
yeah happy birthday thank you
unfortunately I'm looking at my counter
it turns out I have zero time on my
calendar to do anything that would
resemble birthdayness
maybe that is the quintessential David
Eagleman birthday as a calendar that's
completely full that's
neural law at Stanford on Thursday
then I'm having dinner with a startup
that I'm advising then I'm doing my
podcast actually twice this week on
Tuesday and on Friday I'm doing like a
three hour recording session okay this
is very helpful
the Glimpse behind the curtain and what
I'd love to know is
if you had to pick something in there
to use this hypothetical with the Lazy
Susan is there anything that you could
walk us through so let's say you're
getting ready to do the podcast you're
prepping for hours and you're just like
you know what
I am [__] exhausted and it's my
birthday I don't want to be doing this
right now is that the type of case that
you might have or then you would switch
to something else in which case which is
not to throw the podcast under the bus
it's just to say I'm trying to find
something where you're not fully
obligated to other people because I
imagine when you're in a zoom meeting if
you're 30 minutes into 60 Minutes you're
probably disinclined to be like you know
what guys my heart's not in it I'm gonna
focus on my new young adult book that
I'm working on
but is there anything in this week where
you might be able to hypothetically
describe how the Lazy Susan might work
so unfortunately the Lazy Susan can only
get spun on the weekends or something
when there's opportunity to think this
week happens to be a pretty tough one so
I'm constrained at every moment and I
just have to perform but the Lazy Susan
comes in when I say well I've got a four
hour chunk and I'm going to sit down at
IHOP by the way I've written all my
books at IHOPs I don't know why but I
love that it's bottomless coffee and and
it's quiet it's not like a Starbucks
where Attractive people are walking in
and out all the time whatever it's just
like quiet and boring you can just drink
coffee and write but that's where I spin
it because what happens is I'll work on
something and then I'll say oh yeah you
know I really I really want to get to
this other thing and so I'll spin it and
do the other thing and yeah that makes
sense
do you think about how
much of that solo time you want to block
out on a weekly monthly quarterly annual
basis anything along those lines because
I would imagine otherwise it's a
slippery slope and you end up
committed to
a large chunk of your Waking Life
involving other people so there's a
social
pressure expectation that you will not
cancel or move things around so it maybe
creates a degree of inflexibility do you
think about that yes I do think about
that all the time and I really admire
I really admire Tim your four hour work
week as an example I'm working on the
400 hour work week and it sucks because
I'm totally I can totally constrained on
all fronts you seem to be having a good
time I'm having a good time and it's my
own fault the thing is I can't reach
this new shiny objects so every time
some student says Hey I want to start a
company will you help me and be an
advisor I'm like heck yeah that sounds
amazing and I do that every time I come
up with a new idea for a screenplay or
book or whatever I'm like that's the
greatest idea and I jumped in on it so
you may not want to start a venture
capital firm you'll end up saying yes to
everything
one of my mentors Ed shell incredible
entrepreneur also was a competitive
figure skater than a congressman and
took a couple of companies public he
taught computer science I think he was
the first or maybe the second to ever
teach computer science at Stanford and
he tried to become a venture capitalist
he did become one at one point he
realized I'm not any good at this I get
too excited I have to say
let's talk about live wired and this
question was cued for me in a way by
Annika Harris
who's an incredible writer it's written
a lot on Consciousness the topic we
covered at the very beginning of this
conversation on some level infotropism
am I getting this yeah term right could
you walk us through the premise of
Livewire the reason for writing it and
then unpack infotropism if you wouldn't
mind okay so live wired in general is
about this issue of how you can't really
think about the brain like Hardware or
software but instead it's what I call
liveware where it's reconfiguring itself
all the time this thing I mentioned
earlier brain plasticity so you know
there's something like 30 000 papers a
year coming out on brain plasticity now
but I wrote this book to sort of
synthesize and build the framework for
understanding what it is for the brain
to absorb the world around it and do
that but what I surfaced that way were
some principles
that were interesting to me and one of
them is about yeah infotropism is a term
that I coined about
what the brain is trying to do at all
times it's reconfiguring a circuitry so
that it can maximize the information
that it brings in from the world so just
as an example if you're watching a
waterfall you know we've probably all
had experience you're staring at a
waterfall for a while and then you look
over to the rocks and trees at the side
it looks like everything's moving up
this is called the motion after effect
where you see motion moving in the
opposite direction
I make a long argument but I'll just say
in a sentence here that what the brain's
trying to do is say okay I'm going to
reset my zero I'm going to recalibrate
so that I can see if there's more
information here because I don't want to
just essentially what it would be trying
to do is cancel out the downward motion
because it says okay there's lots of
that but there's no new information
there so I'm trying to cancel that out
and it does it by you know having this
upward motion there's more sophisticated
arguments about how it does this gnarly
I'm just doing that to maximize the
information same if I change the color
of the lights in the room let's say I
make it all red
your brain will quickly stop seeing the
red and it will adjust itself so that
it's seeing other things so it can
maximize what it's pulling out at all
times of course you know this if you put
on let's say yellow sunglasses or
something everything looks normal after
a moment
until you take them off again anyway so
this is a general thing that the brain's
always
trying to do is say how can I pull the
most useful information out of the World
by recalibrating everything else around
me what was your hope for or hope in
publishing that book
what would you like people to take from
that or what would you like people to
grab and run with from that
I think the notion of how plastic the
brain actually is is something that's
totally underappreciated there's sort of
uh an idea that I think many people have
which is oh you're just born with a
brain the brain kind of unpacks and then
you're who you are but really we are
totally functions of our culture and our
society and what one of the things
that's amazing to me is like imagine Tim
that you and I were born you know 10 000
years ago exactly the same DNA but we
wouldn't be anything like what we are
now even though with the same DNA we
might look vaguely like we do now but my
God the culture everything we're pulling
in would be so different
and that's what actually shapes a human
being
and I actually started off the book with
a quotation from Heidegger who says
oh it's something like every man begins
life is ten thousand men and dies is a
single one and what that means is you
know you've got all this potential all
this these directions you could go in
your life but as you move through life
and you make choices and stuff happens
to you
you end up exactly who you are
I'm looking at Martin Heidegger it's fun
to find it tell me if this sounds right
to you
anyone can achieve their fullest
potential
who we are might be predetermined but
the path we follow is always of our own
choosing we should never allow our fears
or the expectations of others to set the
frontiers of our destiny and then
there's the pop-up to continue with
Facebook thank you Goodreads they come
back your destiny can't be changed but
it can be challenged every man is born
as many men and dies as a single one
right right nice
let me ask you then about
just a thought exercise if we look
through the telescope
into the future or
the probably the scrying ball look into
the scrying ball and try to figure out
what might be coming down the pike
knowing what you know and having the
breadth of exposure that you have within
science and outside of science
let's just say in the next 10 years the
next decade what current assumptions
about the brain perception or reality do
you think
potentially going to be overturned or
that might be ripe for challenging I
think the main thing has to do with
technology as opposed to theoretical
ideas so what I mean is we've got plenty
of theoretical hypotheses all about how
the brain might be working and so on but
we actually don't have any good
technology for measuring what's going on
inside the brain so you know we've got
brain Imaging where you see these fancy
images of brains with
false color images on its own but but
it's really crude that's fmri that's
just measuring where the blood flow goes
and you're measuring cubes of millions
and millions of neurons at once
and all you can say is oh there was some
activity there somewhere in that Cube so
what we really need is a technology that
allows us to measure the spiking
activity of every neuron in the brain
let's say 86 billion neurons all at once
in in real time ideally and then do
massive computational analysis of that
to understand what is the language of
the brain somehow we know it involves
these spikes
but we haven't cracked the neural code
yet so in the same way that Francis
Crick and James Watson cracked the
genetic code oh it's a c t g and the
whole thing is just about keeping the
order of the base pairs and all the rest
is just housekeeping
we haven't figured out what the neural
code is yet so what we're facing I don't
know if it'll be 10 years hopefully
maybe at least 20 or 100 but
what we're facing is a giant leap in
understanding that we know is coming but
we just don't have the the trick cracked
yet
so that's one thing was your question
about any kind of invention or
Neuroscience in particular it could be
broader than Neuroscience but I was
thinking related to the brain the Mind
perception hmm
really anything that checks any of those
boxes but we can we can go beyond that
what I find so mesmerizing and
frustrating about humans and of course
I'm one of those so I put myself in the
same group it's just how
certain we are at so many points and I
know
you have quoted Voltaire before saying
uncertainty is an uncomfortable position
but certainty is an absurd one but if
you look back especially in the history
of medicine let's just say and how
certain humans are including let's just
call them top specialists in any given
field
that what they know to be true or think
to be true is true and then it gets
overturned and then it gets overturned
again and then it gets overturned again
which is not to create a sort of
relativism that we can't know anything I
think that's sort of a learned
hopelessness it's not very helpful but
I'm wondering sort of as someone who has
experience as a practitioner of science
also an observer of science a
communicator of science
a deep thinker on these subjects
what might be worth stress testing
or
things that we currently take to be true
that may in fact not be true doesn't
need to be contained to Neuroscience
though I mean this is the beauty of
science is that it's always willing to
knock down its own walls and so this is
what the scientific method is about and
it's the most special thing that humans
have ever done because everything else
is about how do I sort of establish
my throne and I set this up and no one
can question this but there's nothing in
science that isn't vulnerable to getting
knocked off its pedestal and so in fact
much earlier in the podcast when you
asked me about what if you have
Consciousness whether it's emerging
property or whether Consciousness is a
fundament who the heck knows and I think
as you get older and more mature as a
scientist you feel like okay I don't
know I don't know we'll see we'll do
experiments we'll figure it out but
there's no need to pretend certainty on
things and in fact that's always driven
me crazy and one thing I walked into a
bookstore this is many years ago about
the time that that some came out
actually walking to the bookstore and
there was
a table of books on the front and one
was by religious fundamentalists one
pile and the other pile was by the Neo
atheists and the table was set up is
like you know this battle between these
but as you know from reading some it's
all about shining a flashlight around
the possibility space it's all about
saying God who knows what's going on
here let's just make up a bunch of
stories let's make up 40 stories and we
can make up 400 more and so
that idea you may know this but years
ago I proposed this new
movement called possibilianism which
really caught on and actually is still
moving around the planet well but the
idea with possibilianism is avoiding
committing to something with certainty
if you don't need to and really this is
just an expression of the scientific
temperament
science is always the one to say look
what we can have is the weight of
evidence at any given time we say oh
that supports this morning this okay
great so we'll sort of provisionally
believe this to be true
but it's not about
pretending certainty when we don't have
enough data and when it comes to some
fundamental questions like our existence
here what I mean we don't have any data
on that we don't have enough to know if
I mean certainly religion we have enough
data to know that all those biblical
stories are completely made up and wrong
in a thousand ways but we certainly
don't have enough evidence to say oh
therefore there's nothing interesting in
the cosmos besides us
I mean who knows so yeah in my very
limited muggle experience of Science and
life really the best people
they're true
outliers in terms of intellectual
horsepower and performance say I don't
know a lot and I remember going on a
walk with someone recently and they
wanted to get my two cents back Channel
reference check on someone
and my commentary was pretty simple it
was well
clearly very smart in a lot of ways but
almost no low conviction statements and
that makes me a little nervous
everything is a high conviction
statement and that gives me some pause
so you're right I think the reserving
the space for uncertainty and to the
extent possible for me at least trying
to find that
exciting the fact that there's still so
much unmapped territory as opposed to
debilitating
David I'm going to ask you a question
that is sometimes a terrible question
but I'll throw it out there anyway and
we can delete it if it doesn't pan out
which is the metaphorical billboard
question if you could put
anything on a billboard non-commercial
of course to get out to
hundreds of millions or billions of
people could be a quote could be a word
could be an image could be someone
else's quote
anything at all does anything come to
mind
I think I would put a billboard
next to an elementary school or maybe
Junior higher high school
I don't know I'd have to think about
this it was something like you know
question your truth because this is the
issue that we're always in is
I've been faceted by this issue so you
know the brain locked in and silence the
darkness comes up with an internal model
of the world with all of its truth this
is political truths all that stuff
and the funny part is that when you look
at someone else let's say on the
opposite side of the political Spectrum
from wherever you are you think oh that
person's misinformed they're a troll if
I just talk to them long enough they'd
come to agree with me and so on weird
Everybody believes this and everyone on
all sides of the spectrum thinks okay I
clearly see the truth and I don't know
why those other people don't so I've
just been fascinated by this issue about
how completely we believe our internal
models so
that's what I would try to do with young
people anyway is just get them to
question this issue
to minimize their High conviction
statements so how would you let's just
use the elementary school or High School
example this applies to more than that
but let's just say in this case how
would you try to frame this or spin it
so that there's some self-interest right
in terms of not just the
maybe more General become a better
thinker a better human
a better member of society is is there a
way that you could position
that cross-examination of One's Own
thoughts and beliefs
in maybe a sort of a craster way for
self-interest just to get more people to
do it right okay I don't know if this is
going to answer the question directly
but one way to get people there is to
for example if you admire Sherlock
Holmes or you know if a kid watches the
Benedict Cumberbatch version or whatever
you think wow that guy is really
noticing things and that's when you
start realizing the limits of your own
internal monitor you think wow you know
I would have never noticed that why
because I didn't pay attention to that I
didn't care about that but if you admire
people who can do things and solve
things then I think it's in your
self-interest to say I want to expand my
internal model I'm not satisfied to say
okay I've got it I know the truth I'm
not going to do any more work
so something along those lines of
inspiring people that way I suppose
house would fit in there but he's kind
of a dick as a character so I'm not sure
if you want your kids modeling that
what's the impetus and I mean maybe this
is part of the impetus behind the book
that you're working on the one that I'm
working on the big one I'm working on is
called Empire of the invisible and it's
going to take me another few years to
finish this but it is nice title thank
you it's all about this issue of all the
stuff we don't see and don't understand
so I start off with some examples like
we talked about with the electromagnetic
spectrum and all the light you don't see
but forget it it's all about the stuff
that you think your model is complete
and you know everything out there to
know but fundamentally your perception
is like a potemkin village where you
just see the facades of things and if I
scratch the surface on anything like if
I were to ask you hey do you know how
the Electoral College Works you'd say
yeah and I say okay can you explain it
to me let's say no yeah exactly so you
start scratching the surface on things
most people are like Oh I thought I kind
of knew but maybe I don't really know so
that's what it's about and how we can
expand our perception by asking
questions all the time by not taking our
true is so seriously by understanding
there's more out there
that's what it's about and I'm really
jazzed about this book it's it's right
now it's already 120 000 words as I'm
finishing I gotta really crunch it down
so that any human will read it yeah so
for people who don't
make any sense of word counts I mean I'd
say a lot of books that get published
are around fifty thousand sixty thousand
something like that so you're you're
already punching above your way 75 is my
typical 75 how many words was some
thirty thousand yeah much shorter I
wonder if
just to bring up
the term that one cannot Escape these
days but I wonder if
AI in the cultural conversation context
as people learn more about
AIS plural and large language models and
training data if
more people will become aware of their
own blind spots since we all have our
own training data
right
yeah I wonder if as more of these topics
become mainstream
find their way into
scripted television and so on if people
will become more aware of their own
limitations I mean that would be a lofty
hope not sure if that's going to be the
case I love it I'm not sure I see how
though because we're still stuck in our
internal models so even if I'm talking
to chat GPT and it tells me all kinds of
things I didn't know now I know those
each time I add something new to my
internal model I think okay now I'm
complete I didn't know that now I know a
great I got it now
so I'm not sure how well what I mean by
that is for instance we've been
experimenting on my team with
summarizing past episodes using chat GPT
which I think is an incredible tool but
what what happens in some instances
is the
is the chat interface where I should say
the back end won't interact just with
the training data because I'm curious to
see how it behaves with different
parameters it won't base its summary
strictly on the
transcript that's available on my
website will also pull from say Google
but much of what has been
translated or interpreted or even
summarized elsewhere is completely
inaccurate right so I'll go through or a
team member will go through and they'll
find all these mistakes and it's like
okay interesting if we're looking at
this as the All-Seeing all-knowing
you know sort of monolith of tech that
provides us with answers
we have a lot of problems to solve
it's been a it's been a useful tool for
me to
explore sort of the limitations of sets
of training data but maybe that's I
wouldn't expect it to have that effect
across the board
well remember it's not all seasonal
knowing in terms of knowing the truth
all it is is it's read everything and
it's giving you a summary of everything
so there's people with different
interpretations of what you talked about
that's what it'll let's all know yeah
but it'll serve it up as a
summary but we don't need to deliver the
point it's just I found it to be a
interesting exercise so let me ask this
and this is in some exploratory bullets
that I have listed in front of me that I
was hoping to get to so the one that I
would love to talk about before we
start to wrap is how to make it seem as
though you're living longer
and perhaps you could provide a little
connective tissue to this in context you
know in reading about your history the
story of the construction site when
you're eight years old also I thought
gave a very interesting case study
perhaps of how perception of time can
differ depending on what you're
experiencing right where do you think it
would make sense to take this when I was
a kid I fell off of this house under
construction and and I fell 12 feet and
it seemed to take a long time and I got
really interested in this issue of does
time run in slow motion when you're in
fear for your life I mean I got
interested in that question once I
became a neuroscientist and had grown up
and so I did this experiment I think you
know about this where I dropped people
from 150 foot tall tower in free fall
falling backwards they're caught in a
net below and I measured the speed of
their perception as they're falling
because everybody is it has this
experience or knows similar to this
experience where they get in a car
accident things seem to run in slow
motion and they can report all these
details of what happened anyway long
story short it turns out that the whole
thing is a trick of memory people don't
actually perceive faster during a scary
event it's just that they laid down more
memory so when they read this back out
they say what just happened what just
happened it seems like they've got much
more memory than they would in normal
circumstances
so they say you know I watched the hood
crumple in the rear view mirror fall off
and the expression on the other guy's
face and then okay anyway that got me
thinking about this issue about how we
lay down memory and it turns out that
you know we touched on memory a while
ago but most things in your life you do
not remember you know the number of
cracks in the sidewalk and who is
wearing what and what was on the menu on
the wall that like we just don't
remember almost everything
because the job of memory is to write
down stuff that matters that's
emotionally Salient or informationally
relevant you're just writing this tiny
fraction but anyway when you're
estimating how long it's been since some
event
the way you estimate that is by drawing
on the footage that you have saying oh
well see this happens okay so that must
have been two months since I saw my
friend or it must have been another two
years since I saw this other person that
kind of thing so anyway
this was a whole bunch of research in my
lab over the course of a decade that
came together but the point is
if you're laying down richer memories
you won't necessarily live longer but
you will make it seem as though you've
lived longer because when you're asking
what just happened or how long has it
been you've got more data more footage
to draw on and and of course we all know
this feeling when you go on
some super exciting trip on the weekend
and you come back and you're back on a
Monday you think oh my gosh it's been
forever since it was Friday there's so
many things that happen but if you just
have a normal weekend you think oh my
gosh it's Monday it was just Friday
there's nothing to write down and so you
don't feel that that there was much
duration that happened there
so this is why I think one of the most
important things in life is about
seeking novelty and always putting
yourself in new situations such that
you're laying down dense Memories the
analogy last thing I'll say on this is
when you get to the end of a childhood
summer it seems that the summer lasted
forever and it's because everything is
new so you're writing stuff down in your
memory but when you're older you've seen
it all before and and you get to the end
of a summer and you think wow I can't
believe it's over already I don't really
remember it at all it seems as though
the summer didn't last long
is it fair to
then take from that the key Criterion
for Rich memory as novelty doing new
things exactly
and you know by the way this is one of
the tiny Silver Linings to the pandemic
which otherwise sucked but the one
interesting part from the point of view
of brain plasticity was that it knocked
all of us off our hamster wheels and we
were
finding that the world wasn't what we
expected it was just unbelievable like
if we had talked in 2019 and said hey
could this ever happen we say that's a
great sci-fi story but there's no way
that it would be that weird but it was
actually that weird and we all locked
ourselves in our houses for ten thousand
years and so this is the kind of thing
you know when you go to the store and
there's no toilet paper there on the
shelves it takes your internal model and
it totally says whoa I didn't even know
that could happen you start thinking
about Supply chains and start thinking
about how the world Works you're
thinking about wait is is the barber
shop going to be open can I get a
haircut during pandemic is this coffee
shop going to be open I mean it just
forced us to think about the world
completely new and I think if 2019 had
continued and that it's just been the
same old world we'd actually be
less smart in a sense because our our
internal models just would have never
gotten challenged in that way
[Music]
here's my idiophysis which is an idiotic
hypothesis I think that I come up with
these a lot but I think that we might
actually see a tiny decline in dementia
some decades from now
just because we had this opportunity in
the middle of our Lives to actually kind
of restructure everything and have to
rethink everything going on did you say
idiophysis yeah yeah so with what other
idiotices do you have are there any that
come to mind two a day at least yeah
just you know really really stupid
hypotheses that might just be right but
they couldn't just as well be wrong
maybe I would define an idiophysis as
the kind of hypothesis where I'm not
really attached to it enough to you know
fight and die for it but it's
interesting enough that I'm going to
keep an eye on it and see if I can
collect data on it but I love this term
and I love the idea of sharing some of
them because I imagine
that you might come up with
a lot of hypotheses that might be it's
in some fashion worth examining because
you're also not applying pressure to
yourself
to sort of identify all the scaffolding
apply all the constraints and the
filters and so on okay idiopathies I'm
into it
so David people can find you on
eagleman.com certainly on social David
Eagleman on most things Tick Tock Dr
David Eagleman
and we'll link to everything in the show
notes so books and so on
people can find your new podcast inner
Cosmos with David Eagleman I imagine
wherever fine podcasts are to be found
quite right right and you have many
books I started with some I think it's a
great book but people can start anywhere
is there anything else that you would
like to mention call attention to
any formal complaints you'd like to
Lodge publicly anything at all that you
would like to add before we wind to a
close for this conversation
I can't think of anything else that's
great I think we've covered a lot of
ground all right sounds good well David
thank you so much for the time and to
everybody listening as mentioned you can
find links to everything in the show
notes as per usual at tim.blog podcast
and until next time
be just a little bit Kinder than is
necessary to others and to yourself and
keep experimenting experiment experiment
experiment explore explore explore
novelty folks get after it thanks for
tuning in